elle voir son mari c'était chez moi
bon c'est moi bah si c'est moi la
victime
après la dernière dispute je suis besoin
d'alcool le point ailleurs à peine
arrivé ça se trouve c'est ma mère je
prends quelqu'un est mort et pâques où
il est là debout devant toi vivante
m'envoyait traumatisme est quand même
beaucoup plus vieux que toi en plus
c'était le complètement tout étonné à
quoi à ce qu'ils soient morts doit-on
sur mes roses avec ton sac
si tu touches encore à mes fans je
tenais au magnifique couilles de connard
on aille au lit tu as compris gipsy king
va falloir qu'on cohabitent
alors vous arrangé comme vous voulez à
noter à quoi tes potes trophée mission
de base et nec
c'était dégueulasse je t'emmerde
les casseroles t'emmerde des paliers tel
t'emmerde et la gastronomie française
d'anvers a compris qu'il fallait petite
hausse
l'internement avec toi c'est mignon
baiser comme des bêtes à lui offert chez
de femmes à supprimer médoc chez qui je
sais de quoi tu fais quoi
oui